[Music]
this may sound strange but I'm a big fan
of the concrete block the first concrete
blocks were manufactured in 1868 it was
a very simple idea modules made of
cement of a fixed measurement that fit
together very quickly concrete blocks
became the most used construction unit
in the world they enabled us to build
things that were larger than us
buildings bridges one brick at a time
essentially concrete blocks had become
the building block of our time almost
100 years later in 1947 Lego came out
with this I was called the automatic
binding brick and in a few short years
LEGO bricks
took place in every household it's
estimated that over 400 billion bricks
have been produced or 75 bricks for
every person on the planet you didn't
have to be an engineer to make beautiful
houses beautiful bridges beautiful
buildings Lego making it accessible Lego
had essentially taken the concrete block
the building block of the world and made
it into the building block of our
imagination meanwhile the exact same
year at Bell Labs the next revolution
was about to be announced the next
building block the transistor was a
small plastic unit that would take us
from a world of static bricks piled on
top of each other to a world where
everything was interactive like the
concrete block the transistor allows you
to build much larger more complex
circuits one brick at a time but there's
a main difference the transistor was
only for experts
I personally don't accept this that the
building block of our time is reserved
for experts so I decided to change that
eight years ago when I was at the Media
Lab I started exploring this idea of how
to put the power of engineers in the
hands of artists and designers a few
years ago I started developing little
bits let me show you how they work
little bits are electronic modules with
each one specific function
they're pre engineered to be light sound
motors and sensors and the best part
about it is
they snap together with magnets so you
can't put them the wrong way the bricks
are color-coded green is output blue is
power pink as input and orange is wire
so all you need to do is snap a blue to
a green and very quickly you can start
major making larger circuits you put a
blue to a green you can make a light you
can put an arm in between and now you've
made a little dimmer switch out the
dimmer the knob for a pulse module which
is here and now you've made a little
blinker add this buzzer for some extra
punch and you've created a noise machine
I'm gonna stop then
so beyond beyond simple play little bits
are actually pretty powerful instead of
having to program to wire to solder
little bits allow you to program using
very simple intuitive gestures so to
make this blink faster or slower you
would just turn this knob and basically
make it pulse faster or slower
the idea behind little bits is that it's
a growing library we want to make every
single interaction in the world into a
ready-to-use brick light sound solar
panels motors everything should be
accessible we've been giving little bits
to kids and seeing them play with them
and it's been an incredible experience
the nicest thing is how they start to
understand the electronics around them
from everyday that they don't learn at
schools for example how a night light
works or why an elevator door stays open
or how an iPod responds to touch we've
also been taking little bits to design
school so for example we've had
designers with no experience with
electronics whatsoever start to play
with a little bit as a material here you
see with felt and paper water bottles
we have Jordi making
a few weeks ago we took little bits to
RISD and gave them to some designers
with no experience in engineering
whatsoever just cardboard wood and paper
and told them make something here's an
example of product they made a
motion-activated
confetti cannon ball but wait this is
actually my favorite project it's a
lobster made of play-doh that's afraid
of the dark
[Music]
today's non-engineers little bits became
another material electronics became just
another material and we want to make
this material accessible to everyone so
little bit is open-source you can go on
the website download all the design
files make them yourself we want to
encourage a world of creators of
inventors of contributors because this
world that we live in this interactive
world is ours so go ahead and start
inventing thank you
[Applause]